welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and I honestly
still can't believe that Ant-Man
survived that fight with Kang like a lot
of fans I thought for sure that Scott
was toast especially after seeing that
smashed ant helmet on every square inch
of quantumania's promotional marketing
fortunately Paul Rudd's beautiful
ageless face did not get pulverized but
writer Jeff lovnes has confirmed in
recent interviews that he did think up
several alternate outcomes for the
film's ending during the writing process
we also now know that Red's final scene
in the movie was re-shot in January and
I'm dying to know what the specifics of
those changes were and why they were
made today I'm breaking down some of
loveness's hints at What ant-man's
alternative fate could have looked like
it's safe to say that the internet is
pretty divided on how quantomania should
have played out I think that a lot of
people assumed that Ant-Man would die or
at least face a damaging blow because of
how scary we were promised king would be
but instead of burning Scott out of time
like a kid with a magnifying glass the
Conqueror himself was actually fairly
easily defeated potentially trapped
inside a probability storm and seemingly
taken off the board for now as a comic
nerd I gotta admit I really thought that
giving Scott a heroic sacrifice with
lasting consequences was the Avenue that
they would go down in Avengers number
500 Scott Lang is seemingly killed by
Scarlet Witch Shenanigans this is later
retconned to him being displaced in Time
moments before his death but in any
event this loss of Scott in the comics
propels Cassie to honor his memory by
following in his footsteps just like in
the MCU Comet Cassie and her dad don't
get to spend as much time together as
they'd like to caught in a revolving
door of tragedy that tears them apart
after his apparent death she decides to
pick up where Scott left off helping to
form the Young Avengers so if MCU Kang
beats Scott either by trapping or
killing him we would have had the
perfect segue for Cassie to reach out to
Haley steinfeld's Kate bishop and join
forces in order to recover or avenge him
so many members of The Young Avengers
have been lined up and to me this felt
like the perfect Catalyst to set their
story into motion interestingly however
loveness did kick around a few other
ideas before ultimately deciding to let
the hero of the trilogy say save the day
unscathed one alternate idea for
quantumania's ending would have seen
Scott and hope trapped in the quantum
realm once again with Cassie safe on the
other side in 616. According to some
leaks this was actually the film's
initial ending the January 6th reshoots
of Paul Rudd in the San Francisco
bookends seemingly confirmed that having
Scott Escape was a late addition across
the board in most of the interviews that
I've seen with loveness he really put a
lot of conscious thought into making
sure that quantumania didn't follow the
same beats of previous Marvel movies
here he felt like this ending would have
forced a repeat of Ant-Man and the wasp
and end game in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter leviness said in
regards to trapping Scott in the QR on
paper it seemed thrilling but at the end
of the day we'd literally be copying the
exact same beat for the end of the last
Ant-Man movie there also weren't a lot
of ways to go that were different from
endgame if Scott gets trapped in the
quantum realm like he does in the last
movie's ending then the only way to go
is that he gets out of the quantum realm
like he does in endgame separating
Cassie and Scott once again would have
been more true to their ill-fated father
their daughter relationship from the
comics but loveness is kind of right
we've already seen the Cliffhanger of
Scott trapped in Tiny Town only to
emerge years later at the beginning of
the next team up movie according to
loveness although the idea of killing
Scott was certainly on the table he
ultimately decided against it in that
same Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter he said quote I think people
say that they want that but do you
really want to see Paul Rudd get
murdered in his third movie it was all
debated all discussed and all gameed out
but in The Wizard of Oz you don't want
to see Dorothy die and never go home in
another interview with comicbook.com he
also said at a certain point it feels
expected to kill someone in the third
movie I actually felt the joy of this
movie was having a bit of a joyful
Adventure okay first of all with all due
respect to Jeff loveness there are
plenty of Heroes who go out in a blaze
of glory at the end of their run have
you seen Logan that [__] won awards but
love Miss's choice to keep Ant-Man
bloodied but alive actually had a lot
more to do with Kang than it did with
Scott Lang in that same Hollywood
Reporter interview when asked about Kang
potentially racking up some kills he
said we certainly gamed out a ton of
scenarios but it just felt a little
obvious it's Up For Debate but it just
felt like we'd be copying the Thanos
approach where he comes in pretty heavy
and wipes the floor with everybody so
the ending of quantumania was a
conscious effort to make sure that
Kang's introduction to the MCU felt
nothing like thanos's that dude showed
up and cleared out half of existence in
one second flat the sheer Terror he
inflicted so casually and
instantaneously was palpable to the
audience but Jeff loveness wanted to
create more of a slow burn for his big
bad to The Hollywood Reporter he said
quote well I think you root for someone
who knows defeat Thanos says that he
knows what it's like to lose but we
never see him lose until the end of end
game all he does is toss away the people
that he loves and beat Thor's ass Loki
also loses pretty hard in that first
Thor movie and so by the time he rolls
back around we get more of his baggage
but once again the big distinction
between Thanos and Kang is that Kang is
more of a human being and so his defeat
was a way to Showcase his humanity and
his unending passion if you go back in
the comics you you can beat Thanos once
and that's the end of the day Kang is
not a guy that you can beat once he's an
existential problem leviness wanted the
Conqueror to lose his first fight
because light Kang the MCU has nothing
but time to build up to this legion's
true Horrors comparing the way that he
shaped Kang's lost to Scott to Loki's
loss to Thor was super interesting to me
because it gives us the Glimpse at just
how many sides of this character we're
really gonna see this ending has forced
us to let our guard down on King just a
little bit after all we've now seen he
who remains stabbed by Sylvie and the
Conqueror killed or trapped in a cosmic
Pokeball by a guy who got fired from
Baskin Robbins remember in Infinity War
when the shield went up around wakanda
and all those aliens started dive
bombing their way through the first
round of those suckers might have gotten
sliced up but the sick little freaks
behind them were able to push their way
inside think of these first two kings
like the first wave of creatures it
seems like they're out of the way but
really they're just opening the gate for
More Kings to come through for those of
us who were dying to see a Kang
Smackdown in quantumania loveness has
some comforting words loveness
toldcomicbook.com I think for these
bloodthirsty fans there's a little movie
called Avengers the Kang Dynasty I think
he'll bring the heat in another
interview with io9 he advised us not to
worry too much about King's kill count
promising that his many variants will
rack up some kills as he goes along in
spite of all of his wins defeating
Darren cross helping to rescue Janet Van
Dyne saving the world alongside his
fellow Avengers in the battle for Earth
leaving Kang in Quantum timeout Scott is
finally facing the big question that all
heroes eventually face did he do the
right thing by preventing the Conqueror
from escaping based on the mid and
post-credit scenes leviness's reasoning
for King's loss and his plans for a
bloodbath in Kang Dynasty I honestly
don't know if he did winning this
particular battle might be fine and
dandy now but there's gonna be a greater
cost nothing happens in the Multiverse
without a ripple effect and right now
there's no way of knowing the potential
amount of future damage Scott's actions
may have caused follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at whitneypuppy follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]